the focus is Grace it's not on being  good it's not on these lofty ideas of  progressive sanctification I think that  people instead of focusing on Grace like  to focus on being good but being good is  never  Set Me Free in the way that um truth has  and things that have interrupted me from  outside of me it inherently means the  ball's not in our court you can't earn  it it's not something that you climb  toward it's something that you get and  on some level we think if it's free it  must be worthless and having a community  a spiritual Community that's based on  Grace and on just being a beloved child  of God and on the fact that yeah you're  simultaneously Center and Saint we all  [ __ ] up and we can move on because  there's Grace for all that when that's  the main message it ends up people make  pretty good decisions for themselves  without the church having to tell them  what those look like